germany has announced a new blueprint
for relations with
asia calling in particular for diversity
in its focus
in the region that's being interpreted
as an effort to lessen
its dependence on china a move that
would
almost certainly have consequences for
german businesses
from its mass internment of uyghurs in
xinjiang
to its crackdown in hong kong and the
sharpened edge of its diplomacy in
recent years
china is politically a growing problem
for germany
economically china is a golden goose
on average german blue chip companies
earn 15
of their revenues from china some go
further
china accounted for more than 40 percent
of turnover for volkswagen in the first
half of 2020
34 for bmw and 22
for adidas and that gives china leverage
in the relationship
the new guidelines from the german
foreign ministry are meant to begin
correcting that imbalance
one key word diversification
spreading out amongst more countries for
strategic and trade partnerships
foreign minister heiko maas told his
chinese counterpart wang gui
this week that his country wanted to be
seen as an equal
we won't allow it that we become the
plaything of a superpower competition
between the united states russia and
china
we want to be in dialogue with everyone
easier said than done many german
businesses are wary of endangering their
relationship with china
well on this let's speak to gabrielle
felbermeier who's president of the keel
institute
for the world economy here in germany
thanks a lot for joining us
so the german government has been pretty
clear in its criticism
of certain chinese policies uh the
treatment of the uyghurs and the
hong kong security law but how much
clout does germany
actually have i mean is it a big enough
trading partner to make a difference
yes germany is a big trading partner of
china it's also a technology partner
and it has grown in its importance
because of course
the united states is decoupling from
china so
indeed germany has clout in this
relationship and
uh is an important factor
in uh pushing china towards more
reciprocity
and towards a more balanced relationship
heiko mars and other european leaders
have talked about
the europe as a whole being a bit more
self-confident
in the face of china what's been lacking
in the european approach there
uh well i think that's very easy it's
unity uh
and you know we all know about the 16
plus one initiative where china
actively tries to drive a wedge
between the european countries uh of
course
germany is much more exposed to the
chinese economy than say france or spain
or italy so there are different
interests within europe that make
unity more difficult but it's important
now with these new guidelines that the
germany
takes the driving seat that it does more
to unite
europe behind a very balanced and
reasonable approach which is now led out
in this new paper
now europe should ultimately be wanting
to compete with the likes of
china and the united states not just
trade with them
what would that look like how can europe
compete with these enormous superpowers
first of all it's important that we
you know get more convinced of our own
strengths
europe is an important uh player in
international trade some say that europe
is the
uh trading superpower we are the largest
trade partner
of many countries and uh it is in
particular this
strategic rivalry between china and the
united states that gives
europe extra clout and so i'm not a
pessimistic
per se what we need to have is a clear
strategy
and what we also need to do is
pursue a balanced approach that is not
not the targeting to restrict trade but
tries to open more trading possibility
with
other partners in asia that's what this
paper is calling for and i think for
that reason it's a very good approach we
need to
push the trade agreements that are being
negotiated with countries like indonesia
or with other asean partners
we need to bring china to the
negotiation table and conclude this
investment agreement that has been
under negotiation for too long now so
there is a lot to be done
and germany can play an important role
here
using those tools of international trade
diplomacy
just very briefly so what are the target
areas of asia you mentioned
uh southeast asia beyond china where's
germany looking
well in this specific paper that's been
published yesterday
that the germany is looking in
particular the asean countries
indonesia being the largest and fastest
growing amongst them
we already have trade agreements for
example with singapore but others
are under negotiation or are in
difficulty for example with thailand or
malaysia
i think this target is exactly right and
the second big power of course in the
area is india
and germany has not yet developed a a
good strategy to deal with that
country that potentially is larger in
terms of population than
uh than china and also has a lot to a
lot ground to grover
to cover in terms of economic
development an
india strategy is as important for this
reason
for this region than a smart way to deal
with china
gabriel fergul meyer from the keel
institute for the world economy thanks
for joining us
you